ma veramente vuoi cambiare lavoro
ma scusami ma dici sul serio cioè per i
prossimi due anni tu non guadagnerà in
una lira
no aspetta fammi capire
vuoi veramente andare a lavorare con un
gruppo di uomini tutti i tatuati su dati
che parlano solo di sesso e lasciare il
tuo ufficio
certe volte per volenti capisco
queste sono alcune delle cose che mi
sono state dette quando ho deciso di
cambiare carriera io ho una vita
abbastanza particolare sono molto felice
di questo ho iniziato in realtà come
procuratrice legale per poi passare per
dieci anni di grafica e poi finalmente
laurearmi in arti culinarie
le cose che ho fatto prima di diventare
cuoca in realtà non le rinnego affatto
anzi sono molto contenta di averle fatte
poi però ho pensato che forse la parte
di me la parte creativa che non avevo
mai sviluppato in precedenza è proprio
quella in cui potevo riuscire meglio e
ne ho fatto davvero un gol ho detto
nella mia vita io vorrò sempre fare
quello che mi piace perché secondo me se
una persona fa quello che piace e non
solo il vero lusso ed è sicuramente la
situazione in cui si riesce meglio
un paio di anni fa mi hanno chiesto di
scrivere un libro per cui ho pensato
va bene a cosa scrivo di cosa scrivo
sono una cuoca ovviamente la prima
richiesta quella più naturale era
scrivere di ricette e ho pensato io non
voglio scrivere un libro di ricette
scrivere un libro di ricette mi sembrava
quasi banale non che gli altri libri di
ricette le fossero tutt'altro ma ero io
non volevo volevo fare qualcosa di
diverso
soprattutto perché in un campo maschile
io ero riuscita a sfondare determinate
situazioni per cui volevo essere di
esempio a da altre ragazze che volevano
intraprendere questo lavoro così da te
che io ogni giorno ricevo tantissime
poste elettroniche o telefonate oppure
addirittura ragazze passano dal
ristorante mi chiedono consiglio sento
davvero tantissime cose che sono
aberranti per certi versi nella serie
una ragazza di 24 anni che vuole
diventare cuoca e si dice o ma è troppo
tardi troppo tardi
io ho cambiato carriera quando avevo
oltre 30 anni e non ho avuto un attimo
di dubbio che la mia età potesse essere
un ostacolo era tutto qui dentro ed è
quello che volevo fare ed era quello che
volevo trasmettere nel mio libro
quindi ho messo giù una serie di
principi ho pensato ma forse questo
potrà aiutare qualcuno perché
molte delle cuoche delle chef
famosissime bravissime incredibili a cui
mi sono anche ispirata
precedenti
generalmente hanno iniziato la loro
carriera perché il loro marito il loro
padre il loro fratello qualcuno in
famiglia aveva deciso di aprire un
ristorante e loro si sono ritrovate in
cucina io invece volevo che la mia fosse
una scelta professionale differente miei
genitori non erano in questo mondo ne
tantomeno qualcuno vicino a me né
tantomeno mio marito il mio compagno per
cui volevo volevo veramente iniziare da
zero in un mondo in cui in realtà non
avevo nessuno che mi appoggiasse non
solo questo paradossalmente ha giocato a
mio favore perché specialmente quando mi
sono trasferita a roma ho avuto
tantissimi ospiti illustri giornalisti
di cui non conoscevo nulla
quindi ho deciso di mettere giù questi
principi nel mio nel mio libro
queste sono le cinque regole perché
secondo me tramite queste regole weekend
locked futures la prima trova la forza
di essere diversa questa è una delle
cose il mio principio fondamentale
attraverso il quale ho vissuto davvero
tutta la mia e devo tutto a mia madre
perché mia madre sembra retorico
sempre la mamma o la nonna invece in
realtà è proprio così ma la cosa
incredibile è che i miei genitori
vengono da un paese piccolissimo mia
madre ma è nata a trinitapoli ha vissuto
a cerignola stiamo parlando del profondo
sud specialmente di tantissimi anni fa
eppure i miei genitori mi hanno fatto
fare il primo viaggio all'estero quando
avevo 14 anni da sola con
un'organizzazione ovviamente ma comunque
da sola incredibile perché questo ha
aperto secondo me un mondo che non
pensavo esistesse da lì è iniziata una
un'educazione diversa un modo di vedere
le cose diverso soprattutto un
abbracciare le altre culture diverse e
questo lo devo veramente a mia madre che
mi ha sempre detto ricordati che la vera
forza è quella di essere diversa io lo
vedo con mio figlio mio figlio a sette
anni ho sempre parlato inglese da quando
è nato
eppure mi risponde in italiano un certo
punto iniziato a preoccuparmi ho detto
ma perché io vallo inglese e lui mi
risponde in italiano per cui parlando
con una psicologa mi ha detto no è
proprio questo è il principio del peer
pressure è questo ho iniziato a pensare
tutti i bambini vogliono essere uguali
agli altri
così mi è stato spiegato e poi ho
pensato tutte le donne fanno così tutte
le donne vogliono essere uguale alle
altre ci vestiamo nella stessa maniera
parliamo nella stessa maniera guardiamo
le stesse cose in tv vogliamo anche fare
gli stessi lavori non è questo il vero
lusso la vera il vero momento in cui
week è na locked feature è quando noi
ritroveremo noi stesse e faremo
esattamente quello che vorremmo
ed è questa la strada che io ho cercato
di seguire durante tutta la mia vita
allora ho pensato come posso sempre nel
libro come posso pensare per esempio
ad un piatto perché ovviamente io vivo
in questo mondo quindi dovevo in ogni
caso illustrare un principio con un
piatto questo è uno dei piatti storici
fatto il 2006 voi direte va beh è un
panino che ho capito cosa c'è di strano
nel 2006 nessuno parlava di panini
nessuno ha mai servito un panino
soprattutto in un ristorante che poi ha
ricevuto la stella michelin
tanto è vero che quando andai dal mio
socio e di si sa io voglio mettere
questo piatto in carta si tratta di un
panino alla liquirizia con una scaloppa
di foie gras e un finto ketchup di mango
è una maionese al passito con delle
patatine fritte
lui mi guardò e disse
questa è nota perché io non so se
riuscirei a farlo diano veramente vuoi
mettere un panino io ho detto io voglio
mettere un panino perché secondo me è la
maniera per fare un crossover
praticamente cercare di identificare un
modo di ristorazione diverso rispetto a
quello del passato classi ristorante che
che a roma è un ristorante che ha
ricevuto la stella michelin ed è nato 11
anni fa senza tovaglie cosa che oggi
insomma oggi si va nei ristoranti non ci
sono le tovaglie ma un progetto di 12
anni fa con un'apertura di 11 anni fa
senza tovaglie era già una grossa
evoluzione della cucina doveva seguire
lo stesso ritmo e doveva seguire la
stessa linea
ed è per questo che quando io sono
entrata lì dentro mi sono sentita a casa
ha detto questo è il posto dove io posso
esprimere me stessa e non sono uguali
alle altre l'ho sempre pensato e
continuo a pensarlo ma io penso che
ognuno di noi dovrebbe pensare una cosa
del genere
il secondo principio è sappi sempre dove
andare perché vedete le donne questa è
un'altra cosa che non facciamo spesso
molte volte non abbiamo il coraggio di
dichiarare a noi stesse dove vogliamo
andare un po perché abbiamo paura poi
soprattutto e spesso pensiamo di non
esserne capaci oppure di non meritarselo
è facile sentire un uomo che parlando
con il proprio capo dice io in un anno
voglio diventare capo di questo reparto
ho sentito proprio 1 ieri in treno e ho
pensato ho mai sentito una donna di una
cosa di questo genere no
quando invece la si sente purtroppo e
questo è statisticamente è provato e
tramite studi quando una donna afferma
determinate cose purtroppo le accezioni
sono più attive che positiva
quando lo dice un uomo sono positive
quando lo dice una donna sono negative
allora io ho pensato io voglio sapere
dove voglio andare voglio sapere chi
vorrà essere in un anno due anni tanto è
vero che quando ho cambiato carriera mi
sono data 10 anni di tempo ho detto se
in dieci anni non riesco a sfondare ok
tornerò a fare qualcos'altro due lauree
parlo tre lingue un lavoro lo troverò e
quindi mi sono detta sempre parlando del
libro cosa posso fare qual è il piatto
che voglio accoppiare a questo principio
ed è questo questo è il piatto che mi ha
portato in giro per il mondo è un
pastore di lingua e di
lingua il passato in realtà è ebreo
quindi io sono andata agli stati uniti a
new york sono andati in tre posti molto
famosi ho studiato come si faceva il
past rami sono tornata a roma e ho
applicato ad un pezzo di carne che è
tipico della tradizione laziale volevo
onorare in fondo il posto dove io sono
tornata che mi ha dato tanta felicità è
tanto lusso in questi ultimi dieci anni
e quindi ho fatto questo pastrami di
lingua prima ancora che la parola passa
miele tecnica di pastrami di venissero
nuovamente comuni infatti mi fa molto
piacere quando io faccio una cosa due
anni in anticipo e poi diventa famosa
significa che sono sulla strada giusta
questo è un piatto che è stato
presentato a identità golose un convegno
al quale partecipo al quale ho avuto la
fortuna di partecipare in passato e che
ha veramente
informazioni incredibili riguardo
proprio a noi donne perché ora vi spiego
terzo principio rispetto a te stessa e
il mondo in cui vivi
importantissimo principio
perché soprattutto attraverso il
rispetto di noi stesse noi possiamo
raggiungere i nostri obiettivi
prima parlavo di identità golose sono
stata la prima speaker donna che è stata
chiamata sul palco centrale a parlare
per cui mi sono detta di cosa parlo
perché secondo me c'è una
responsabilità nei confronti di chi
quando ci viene chiesto di cosa parlare
nei confronti di chi ci ascolta e ho
pensato il principio rispetto era quello
che dominava quel compagno e io ho detto
ok io parlerò della fermentazione
sono stato a mi vanto di essere versata
la prima parlare di fermentazione in un
convegno
lo sapete perché l'ho fatto
mi ricordavano in un certo senso anche
la nostra vita io ho parlato del chimici
in particolare della tecnica del chimici
e un cavolo eppure la fermentazione con
il nostro controllo e con la nostra
passione e la nostra cura dalla
possibilità l'ingrediente di raggiungere
il massimo esponenziale possibile quel
cavolo è diventato chimici ed è una cosa
assolutamente di una bontà unica oltre a
far bene e ora non è stato fatto nulla
di straordinario è stato c'erano le
condizioni giuste per che questo potesse
accadere ed è questo quello che mi ha
attratto tantissimo della fermentazione
o associato immediatamente con la
tecnica di fermentazione al rispetto
quindi al rispetto dell'ingrediente ma
anche al rispetto di noi stesse e
fondamentale avere rispetto di se stesse
attraverso le proprie azioni
questo è uno dei principi che mi piace
di più potete notarlo dai miei capelli
poi scendi embolo contro gli stereotipi
della donna in cucina e fuori sono
sempre stata una persona che non ha mai
creduto o meglio ha sempre pensato di
dover sfondare determinati stereotipi lo
so ora dirò una cosa che probabilmente
li farà sorridere specialmente alle
nuove generazioni quando io mi sono
laureata in giurisprudenza ha voluto
mettermi un paio di pantaloni per andare
discutere la tesi cioè la mia famiglia
era terrorizzata scandalizzata vuoi
mettere un paio di pantaloni si voglio
mettere un paio di pantaloni perché non
era normale che una donna si mettesse un
paio di pantaloni per andare a discutere
la propria tesi da quel momento in poi
ho sempre fatto ho sempre cercato di
andare controcorrente se qualcosa era
necessario
socialmente accettato ed era quasi o
appunto uno stereotipo io ho cercato di
sfondarlo anche nel momento in cui ho
deciso autonomamente di intraprendere
una carriera completamente diversa
rispetto a quella della mia famiglia
il piatto che vi associato e questo è
l'ultimo piatto possiate che è stato il
piatto più probabilmente più fotografato
di questo convegno è associato a
quest'anno io sono una promotrice della
difesa delle api e quindi anche di tutto
ciò che ne deriva in questo caso il
miele o associato foto un piccolo gioco
una trippa nido d'ape e nello stesso
tempo a una salsa a base di idro miele e
mela e miele ed è una rivisitazione di
una zuppa messicana questo piatto mi ha
portato tanta fortuna quest'anno e mi ha
fatto soprattutto scoprire che ci sono
tantissime cose che noi donne possiamo
fare bene non meglio degli uomini perché
io non credo nella esclusione ma credo
nella inclusione apro parentesi chiudo
parentesi di società più resistenti sono
le società inclusiva non quelle
esclusive quindi io ritengo invece di
essere un esempio spero di essere un
esempio per coloro che vogliono
intraprendere questa carriera in poche
parole cosa che voglio dire io voglio
dire a tutte le donne soprattutto quelle
che stanno iniziando questa carriera ma
non soltanto quella nell'ambito del
della cucina ma in tutte le carriere che
è arrivato il momento che noi qui al
loft feature forio
noi dobbiamo credere in noi stessi
perché noi possiamo
siamo intelligenti siamo capaci possiamo
dirlo ad alta voce e sarebbe arrivato il
momento che lo facciamo per davvero